[Music]
do
so
[Music]
hi good evening
good to see you all
so welcome to the table we are thrilled
that you're here my name is don jacobs
i'm one of the uh leadership team
members here and i'm just thrilled that
you guys are here part of us um this
sunday it's lay ray weekend so hope you
guys are
relaxing and spending time doing exactly
the way that you want to not even
worrying about
you know that thing that makes us money
and just taking a break from it all and
just spending time the way that exactly
the way you want to so you can recharge
and relax
for those of you who are in line thank
you so much for joining us as well
we're glad that you are here too um so
i've got just two quick announcements
one we are not doing our normal
family dinner that we do the first of
the month um after this service so
normally we would go take off and just
have a quick meal together
but because of you know
kovet
ruining everything in our lives right
now um so we're taking a pause because
of safety of course we you know we value
you guys you guys are important to us we
want you guys to be safe
and everything like that so we're just
gonna we're just gonna pause that for a
little bit
um but next sunday we are having a
family meeting of sorts
it's our official state of the table
that we're having right after the
service next sunday so if you want to
hear kind of where we're at it's going
to be like an official meeting we're
going to talk about kind of where we're
at with
all of our different programs that we've
got going on all the different ministry
projects that are going on how we're
doing financially all of it um all the
plans that we've got coming up over the
next several months
so we would love for you to be a part of
that and if that's something you're
interested in
so with all that let's open with prayer
lord thank you so much for this week and
this weekend thank you for bringing us
all here together
thank you for the space
that we can come and sit at your feet
and learn more about you and your son
and then are just our place in
just in all of this i pray you open up
our hearts our minds um to what you want
us to hear
and and so we can walk out of here with
a deep connection with you in christ
saying i pray amen
thanks don and we're so glad to see you
guys so why don't y'all stand with us
josh is going to kick us off on this
first song
feel free to engage all of your senses
because god has made you as a whole
person and we want to engage him with
our whole self so if it feels most
comfortable for you to just sing along
that's great if you want to use your
hands if you would like to clap or stomp
you are invited to do so um or just sit
back and reflect on the words he will
meet us however we come all right
so here we go
[Applause]
[Music]
a man's empty praise
and treasures
[Applause]
never enough
you came
and put me back together
and every desire
is now satisfied
[Music]
and though there's nothing
better than you there's nothing
better than you lord there's nothing
is
[Music]
there's not a
place there's nothing
better than you there's nothing
better than you lord there's nothing
nothing is better than you
oh there's nothing
better than you there's nothing
better than
[Music]
is
you turn shame into glory
you're the only one who
cares you turn graves into gardens
you turn bounds into armies
you turn seasons to highways
you're the
[Music]
you turn shame into glory
you're the only one who came
you turned graves into gardens
you turned bones into armies
you turn seas into highways
you're the only one who cares
you're the only one who
oh there's nothing
better than you there's nothing
better than you love
[Music]
oh there's nothing
better than you or there's nothing
better than you there's nothing
nothing is better than you
[Music]
you turn morning to dancing
you give beauty for ashes
you turn shame into glory
you're the only
you turn graves into gardens
you turn bones into armies
you turn season to highways
you're the only one who cares
[Music]
ignore that last feet
doing some musical chairs tonight
[Music]
jesus
we just invite you into this room
thank you god that you go with us
to the mountains and to the valleys god
in our best moments and in our worst you
are not far from us
you are closer than the air that we
breathe
i pray that we would feel your presence
god
fill us up
meet us here together
[Music]
nothing can
your presence
[Music]
of the sweetest
when my heart becomes free
and my shame is
[Music]
holy spirit
holy
spirit you are welcome
[Music]
your glory
god is
[Music]
your presence
there's nothing worth more
that will ever come close
nothing can compare
you are living
[Music]
sing holy spirit
the
[Music]
is
sing let us become
[Music]
more aware of your presence
let us
[Music]
experience the glory of your
goodness
let
of us presence
let us
experience the glory of your goodness
[Music]
this place
your glory
god is what our hearts long for
to be
over
is
[Music]
to the love that you have
lavished on
[Music]
how can i respond
i don't have much
but i have a heart that beats for you
i have a heart that beats for you
[Music]
every part of me
wants to love you like you
loved me
[Music]
every part of me
wants to love you like you
loved me
my lord
i don't have much
but i have a heart that beats for you
i have a heart that beats for you
i don't have much
but i have a heart that beats for you
i have a heart that beats for you
i have a heart that beats for you yes i
have a heart that beats for you
i have a life i'll give to you
i have a heart that beats for you
i
[Music]
i don't have much
i have a heart that feeds for you
we're gonna move into the prayers of the
people and um if this is your first time
with us
we just welcome you guys to participate
in this as you feel comfortable
but it's really an opportunity for us to
join with a tradition that dates way
back um
and it's where all of us together come
together to shoulder the burdens that
we're carrying and lift up the people
that we hold in our hearts
and instead of just carrying that alone
it's a chance for us as a community to
say we care about what you care about
and we believe that god cares about what
we care about
so when we get to the section of the
prayer where we open it up feel free
to
um speak out a name that is on your
heart tonight that might need prayer or
a situation that is burdening you
and then i'll close us out with the very
end of the prayer and if you see words
on the screen that are in red if you
guys could read those all together with
us
it's just an opportunity again for us to
engage this together
so let's go ahead and pray
for the city of saxi and for every city
and community and all of those who live
in them
we pray to you
for the good earth that you have given
us
and the wisdom and the will to conserve
it
we pray to you
for those who travel on land sea or air
for the old and the sick
for the widow and the orphan
for the injured and the suffering
we pray to you
for the poor and the oppressed
the unemployed and destitute for
prisoners and captives
and for all those who remember and care
for them
we pray to you
lord we know that you love us
and that you hear us
and so we lift these names and
situations up to you now
[Music]
josh
um
okay
for these names and moments that we've
spoken aloud and for those that we've
kept in our hearts
we pray to you that they may have life
and light
healing and hope
peace and a deep sense of your presence
amen
the last couple weeks have been really
challenging for our family
um my husband lost his dad
and
we've been grieving that you know in all
of our own ways as a loss of a
grandfather a dad a father-in-law
and um all the surrounding things that
are happening in our world right now so
many other people who have lost loved
ones to covet or have them in hospitals
um or having to quarantine and deal with
the stress
of parenting in the midst of school and
covet and
you name it it just seems like people
are dealing with a lot right now and
what i have found so much comfort in
is just
surrendering my expectations and
what what to me the world should be like
and just believing
that
somewhere in this
ugly mess
that there's a god who loves me and
cares and is walking with us through the
through the midst of it um there's a god
who loves you and he cares about your
story and your journey and your loss he
cares about the things that are
important to you that are on your heart
and i hope that tonight if you leave
with nothing else it's this sense
of the fact that god's love is present
in your life the sense that i belong the
sense that i am cared for i'm valued i
am worthy
um
and i just wanted to close out tonight
with josh leading us through the song it
is well and it's just one of those songs
that um
seems so appropriate for the spirit of
what's going on at least in my world
right now
just that opportunity to be like i don't
have control i can't
predict what's about to happen or what
has already passed
but i can find peace in the midst of
whatever comes knowing that i'm loved
knowing that i'm surrounded knowing that
i'm supported
um so i hope that we can hang on that to
that as a community together
um so would you guys just if you know
this song sing it with us and let it
just be a posture as we close out this
time of our service of just opening up
our lives to god and finding him in the
midst of the storm
[Music]
my way
in those
[Music]
thou
has
taught me to
say
it
is well it
is
well with
my soul
[Music]
is
my
soul
it
is
[Music]
well with
my soul
[Music]
sing that one more time
with my soul
with my
soul
it is well
it is
[Music]
yes jesus thank you for meeting us in
this space together we love you and we
trust you it's in your name we pray amen
if you guys want to turn to the people
around you and say hi as brett gets
ready for the message
please do so
thank you
all right
well good evening everyone
grace and peace
um that was really that was beautiful
that was a holy moment thank you um team
for leading us in that and thank you all
of you for engaging
um
yeah it
was it's just i don't know it's just
something about church it's a unique
space in the culture you know a place to
um come and hopefully be honest
you know if anything else let's be
honest and real about what's going on
and come to god in that way there's
something i don't know something really
meaningful about that and and doing that
with other people you know this culture
we can be so kind of isolated in our own
little worlds going through our own
things not wanting to burden others and
so just that chance to come together in
this way
yeah it just it means a lot it means a
lot so
well i'm so good that you all could be
with us and a warm welcome to those who
are new
as well as those joining us online
we love you a lot
and um we are in a series right now
that's uh it's been going for a while we
we're in part eight of our of our series
deconstruction finding god again
and uh if you're familiar with that that
word deconstruction um
kind of at least what it's come to mean
in our culture in the context of like
religion and such is uh it's really kind
of a season of of doubt a season of
wrestling of um kind of questioning
received kind of inherited beliefs
and so the first
really probably six six or seven weeks
of this um or six weeks of the series
was really taken up with doing a lot of
deconstructing of kind of
inherited christian belief
and that's often what folks are kind of
going through
is wrestling with certain theologies
certain ideas that we've you know
kind of maybe grew up with or even just
kind of got through the culture i know
someone who attends the table who has
like before the tables their first
church ever go to
um
and yet even they had to go through a
season of deconstruction because just in
the culture they picked up ideas about
god about jesus about church and what
church folks thought and maybe god
thought of people like him and you know
there's like a whole thing to kind of
work through even in groping church you
know so
this is kind of a thing that we we often
find ourselves going through the season
of deconstruction so the series is kind
of helping us do that kind of engage
deconstruction engage some
reconstruction um so that was a lot of
the first six weeks i've kind of started
to shift now last week this week will be
the same next week will be similar um
that i'm kind of starting to take us
away from putting that kind of laser
beam of deconstruction onto like
christian ideas and theology um what we
might call certain like bad theology in
christendom which there is there's
plenty i think there's a lot of good as
well um but there's some bad for sure
and uh and so we're kind of redirecting
that beam to um
what we might call kind of so-called
secular culture this idea you know of
the the place like if you leave church
you leave religion behind and then
you're just you know a person in the
culture it's sort of like that's kind of
the waters um that you know all of us at
some level kind of swim in and um
i think what's interesting is
that um you know for even for churches
like ours that are going to be really
open to folks like deconstructing and
you know wrestling with christian belief
and not just you know accepting
everything um i think a little bit of
the trick is
that it's pretty it's it's easy to kind
of um slip into a mode where we are kind
of in constant deconstruction mode and
quite stringent and difficult
as maybe we should be really thoughtful
with church theology but kind of almost
skeptical like i don't know about this
and yet so kind of open
and almost naively
um sort of optimistic about
theology and philosophy and ideas that
are not church it's almost like we're
kind of leaving church and christian
culture behind such that we're so
grateful to kind of deconstruct and like
okay i'm just out of here
that whatever you turn to next we're
like yes i love you you know it's almost
like a maybe a marriage of sorts we've
struggled in the marriage it's been hard
it's been difficult and so
that comes to a close and of course the
next relationship is just like this is
gonna be great they're perfect for me
you know and it's like
well tap the brakes a little you know we
get a little over here so that's kind of
what i'm doing these last few weeks is
trying to get us to think a little bit
harder about um
kind of secular culture and um and not
be too naive in our embrace of that as
we um maybe deconstruct christianity
does that kind of make sense so like
last week we talked about consumerism
and the way that can start to function
as a very strange religion in our lives
kind of has this vision of the good and
we like live into it and you know it's a
it's a strange north dallas religion um
so the title of my message tonight is
deconstruction and the sacred
um
deconstruction the sacred and i want to
talk about
the way that um
that we often i think
can kind of um
leave god behind or even kind of
deconstruct the idea of god and not
necessarily think through
[Music]
the ways that that also means that
that the sacred
the holy like all those categories sort
of also go out the window
and we often don't quite think that
through so that's kind of what this
message is going to be an extended
exercise and trying to kind of think
that um through so i want to start with
a text this is from genesis chapter four
and uh it says this adam
made love to his wife eve yes that is in
the bible
and she became pregnant and gave birth
to cain
and she said with the help of the lord i
have brought forth a man
and later she gave birth to his brother
abel
now abel kept flocks and cain worked the
soil
in the course of time cain brought some
of the fruits of the soil as an offering
to the lord and abel also brought an
offering fat portions from some of the
firstborn of his flock
and the lord looked with favor on abel
and his offering
but on cain and his offering he did not
look with favor
so cain was very angry
his face was downcast then the lord said
to cain
why are you angry
why is your face downcast
if you do what is right will you not be
accepted
but if you do not do what is right sin
is crouching at your door
it desires to have you but you must rule
over it it's quite a chilling image
isn't it it's almost like a
again like some sort of animal kind of
crouching at the door you know some some
sort of or even a predator person who's
sort of behind us you open the door and
you don't see what's behind you know i
mean sort of a creepy horror movie image
in a way
sin is crouching at your door you must
rule over it verse 8. now cain said to
his brother abel
let's go out to the field
while they were in the field cain
attacked his brother abel and
killed him
this of course in the biblical narrative
is the the first murder because this is
you know we have adam eve their two sons
cain abel
then the lord said to cain
where is your brother abel
i don't know he replied
am i my brother's keeper
the lord said
what have you done
listen
your brother's blood cries out to me
from the ground
it's a
it's a powerful story this is um
i think honestly one of the high points
in just like
hebrew kind of poetry mythology stories
like it's incredibly i mean it says so
much that whole story was you know like
10 verses just like i don't know 12 or
13 sentences and just
boom like it just gives the whole
narrative incredibly powerful
um
so i want to unpack this a little bit
obviously kane invites his brother abel
well there's jealousy there's envy going
on
this kind of rivalry
among brothers which isn't um
unusual
and uh
and so he invites me like let's go out
to the field right and of course this is
showing it's premeditated right he's
thinking this through and specifically
he wants to get able away
from the other prying eyes
um but at the end of the story what do
we find out well we understand
that uh
well kane really learned what what the
psalmist in psalm 139 said which is um
you know lord where where can i go where
can i flee from your presence if i go up
to the highest heights there you are if
i go down and make my bed and sheol
there you are if i go east if i go west
if if i hide in the darkness even the
dark is not is not dark to you i mean
you see and that's really what cain
finds out
is there's no hiding right it's like god
sees
god sees
um
but then there's that closing line which
is really what i want to focus on
tonight your brother's blood it cries
out to me from the ground
um
this i think this is this is saying
something more this is more than simply
like god sees
um
or even you know there will be justice
uh what what does this mean your
brother's blood cries out to me from the
ground it's almost as though god is
saying look cain
your brother was not just something
he was someone
he
was holy like he was my creation kane
like he was my creation i'm the creator
you are my creation he was my creation
this brotherly bond this relationship
that you have
is like this is something
sacred
this is something holy
that this
this is this is something more than even
what we tend to think of as just well
you know nature happens you know
fighting happens and sometimes things
die like there's there's something
there's a deeper truth being
communicated here like that there's
almost we might use the language and
we'll see this in a quote later of an
eternal order
that god kind of grounds and roots
where um our actions and what we do
is um is
is is
something deep and profound
and even holy or a violation of the holy
right can you kind of feel the i don't
mean to be overly intense but can you
kind of feel the weightiness of the
story of those closing lines like it's
you kind of almost get the feeling of
god trying to communicate to cain like
look cain this is holy ground
like this this matters
okay so so why am i naming all this um
i'm kind of
what i'm trying to get at tonight is i i
think
that we kind of in the west in the
united states
um we haven't really quite
grasped
all that is really at stake
in either
embracing belief in faith in god
or in the rejecting
of
that
notion or that reality
like we're all um really kind of
believer and unbeliever it strikes me
we're all just a little too chill
and i mean i'm all for you know being
relaxed person whatever i'm not saying
you should be anxious and eaten up with
you know oh my gosh god is oh you know
okay i'm not like saying freak out but
there's almost a kind of um an unhealthy
casualness
to the whole thing
you know it's almost like um
i don't know kind of or christian faith
or even just not even just this isn't
just true of christianity like just kind
of religion in general god in general
it's all sort of cash you know it's all
kind of like oh it's like a hobby or
something you know like oh that's oh
that's nice so you're you're a church
goer oh god good for you that's good
that's good for you you know i'm not
really a church goer but uh you know hey
makes no difference really you know like
we're all just you know good people
and there's there's kind of it's almost
like a
hobby like you know some people are into
these things and some people aren't you
know it's like some people are into
sailing
others into painting
others into praying
you know it's like to each their own
it's a free country do what you want you
know can you kind of can you are you
picking up on the thing like have you
sensed some of this um i mean honestly
all just to be completely candid like i
think there's even a temptation for me
to kind of get this way because it's
just kind of in the waters of the
culture
you know it's sort of like
hey
um
whatever you think that's nice for you
you know but
just uh
yeah so i don't know we i just there's
something that we don't
we just don't get it i don't i don't
think we've really thought this through
we're not quite tracking what is at
stake i want to give you an example this
is a quote from a very um famous atheist
um richard dawkins
uh where this thing this is a good
example of like
okay richard i don't you're just not
quite tracking like you're not quite
getting what is at stake he said uh he
said this we are all atheists
about most of the gods that humanity has
ever believed in
uh some of us just go one god further
can you kind of see the logic there like
okay so hey you're you know a christian
or you're a muslim or like oh you
already don't believe in like i don't
know whatever the number you know 999
god so i'm just you know the only
difference is i just do a thousand you
know like what's the big deal like you
already don't believe i don't believe i
mean do we really believe who cares it
just doesn't matter like can you hear
the kind of i mean sure i guess if you
want to get all worked up and believe in
god or what's okay there's kind of a
it's like okay
no he's not he's not tracking because
because here's the thing um
there there is like i for example as a
christian i have
much more in common way more in common
with um
another person of faith or religious
belief
um than i do someone of no faith and no
belief and like no faith in god
much more so for example me whether it's
to um
uh
most not really the secularized kind of
western weird buddhism but most kind of
buddhism with its kind of understanding
of like the absolute like we've got a
lot of resonance there there's a sense
of the beyond the more
you know like they're it's their way of
kind of talking about the sacred
and i resonate with them i'm like i'm
tracking with you i know what you're
getting at you know i call it god but
it's cool like but there's still there's
a sense of the more you know um or i
have a friend who's a muslim we can chat
we can talk of course we have our
theological differences and our images
of god and such you know um
and yeah there's a certain resonance
like i'm like yep i'm tracking because
there is this kind of a certain belief
in god there is this understanding of an
eternal order
and um
and and even the notions of you know
good and evil and all like we're all
kind of tracking but once you cross kind
of this line of there is like i don't
believe in it's sort of the one god more
thing once you cross that line all of a
sudden
um
you start losing notions of the sacred
and the holy
and even your kind of basis for like
good and evil
and that's why there's starts to become
really a world of difference between
myself and i have trouble even kind of
communicating
at a kind of philosophical theological
moral level with folks who
um
just
have kind of let go of of god um here's
a quote this is kind of he's richard
newhouse he's not he's not commenting on
richard dawkins but he's commenting kind
of on
the idea of what dawkins is getting at
this idea of if god doesn't exist so
he's a i think a catholic philosopher he
says this what happens quote if god does
not exist
is that we are no longer able to see
violence against others as somehow
blasphemous
think and abel
we're no longer able to see as somehow
blasphemous an offense against an
eternal
we're no longer able to see our dealings
with each other as opening on to a depth
of interiority
that we cannot fathom or exhaust
what does that mean in that's kind of a
strange interiority like what it means
is sort of the holy
the sacred
in you
right in that that this is where when i
when i sin against you i hurt you or
someone hurts you or um
violates your you as a person like it's
more than simply like oh i did something
you didn't prefer you know like well
abel preferred that his brother not kill
him and you know it's like no no it's
more than just preferences or something
like this goes deep i love his even his
word blasphemous
there's because what's that kind of
invoking it's this idea of god and the
sacred and the holiness of i'm talking a
lot about human beings but really it's
the whole it's like all of creation it's
sort of alive with god
and that calls us up to something
and um
in other words let me let me kind of try
to phrase this um a little more clearly
so if if god does not exist then it no
longer makes sense to look at people and
see someone holy and sacred because
there is no such thing as holy if god
does not exist it no longer makes sense
to believe in the mystery and the
profound depth of who people are as
creatures made in the divine image
because there is no divine
and therefore
no divine image
if god does not exist then when we lie
or kill or wound people
it is no longer a violation of something
sacred of an eternal order
if god does not exist then ultimately
there's even nothing good
or evil
it's just bits of matter
bumping into others and impacting them
cain is just one mindless animal
killing another
that's some people called abel
i think this it seems to me this is what
dawkins isn't
tracking
that there's there's just a world
there's a world of difference in letting
go of that last
understanding of god at all
um
and again just to be fair i'm kind of
picking on dawkins a little maybe too
much
my point is really that um even as
people fake because you're thinking
we're not atheists why are you right but
i said earlier it's it's everyone we're
all i think we all believers
non-believers christians non-christians
like everyone's kind of in this what
charles taylor called a secular age
we're just kind of swimming in these
waters and the whole thing for us is
just sort of casual and like we just
aren't quite grasping what is at stake
um one way i might put it is without god
there is no foundation for a belief in
the sacredness of others and thus the
very basis for goodness for morality and
for love erodes which is to say that our
very life
and ultimately even if you could contend
our social order like culture
starts to erode
now
um i can imagine maybe more than a few
of you like bruh you are being very
dramatic about this this is not as big a
deal i know plenty of people who like
don't believe in god and they're like
lovely people you know and fair enough
no no like i hear that um
and i'll tell you who actually
um
really got me thinking in this way
because i came across his ideas
um
when i was in my own deconstruction
season and honestly when i was right on
the edge of walking away from god in
church and the whole thing
and i was reading um he's someone i've
mentioned before but it's the german
atheist friedrich nietzsche
and he was actually the one who showed
this to me
because he
um
he's a he was a really thoughtful
atheist his solutions
to these problems were terrifying and
horrible
don't go that road um but he saw the
problem
and what he noticed in the atheism of
his day well i'll read an example this
is he tells this famous um i think i've
read a little bit of this before maybe
two years ago um but it's the parable of
the madman has anyone ever read
nietzsche's parable of the vad man
no just me oh y'all gotta read it it's
amazing you can find it on um online but
he um
so the context well kind of nietzsche
probably is the madman in this little
story he tells so i'll just read a few
sentences and i'll kind of unpack it so
he says this nietzsche writes have you
not heard
of that mad man who lit a lantern in the
bright morning hours and ran to the
marketplace and cried incessantly i seek
god i seek god
as many of those who did not believe in
god
so
this is the kind of fashionable atheism
of his day
because he's writing good 150 years ago
so
a lot of atheism
as many of those who did not believe in
god were standing around just then he
provoked much laughter
has he got lost
asked one did he lose his way like a
child asked another or is he hiding is
he afraid of us has he gone on a voyage
immigrated thus they yelled and laughed
and what he goes on to name
is he basically is saying is now my own
words but i'm paraphrasing like you
don't
get it
his language he says who gave us the
power to wipe away the horizon who gave
us the power to empty out the seas
he says god is dead you and i we have
killed him and he's now he doesn't mean
of course literally god he's he's
talking about like people are no longer
believing he's like god has has bled out
under our knives
and we are unworthy of this deed
and he goes on to articulate he says and
this is why
because
what we don't understand
is
that once god goes
then our entire value and ethics system
that's wrapped up in that theology and
philosophy and story of god also goes
right out the window
but what we do he said it's is basically
we
kill god and then pretend that we can
just go right on living the exact same
values and ethics and
and just kind of keep going on our merry
way as though it's like oh well that
doesn't matter it's fine and he's like
are you crazy
like you can't do this is um what i've
heard he didn't use this language but
i've i've heard this um
called jesus smuggling
anyone ever heard that term
this is this is this is what i've
noticed most folks do even when they
deconstruct kind of god christian faith
it's like oh i'm just done with church
it's crazy i just can't do all this
i and
know i just can't do this and we kind of
move on
and
what is jesus smuggling it's it's where
we well let me give let me read you a
few examples um these are ones i've seen
people do on facebook where they'll say
something like you know
i don't read the bible anymore
you know it's just silly fantasies and
then
um
they'll turn around and say but i
believe in the sacredness and dignity of
every human person
can you see what here's and here's what
they're doing it's just this chapter one
it's the divine image
right that's the origin if you trace
those ideas back it's like they're
talking about as the world as though
there is still something sacred as
though there's still a more um here's
another one
um
is
uh you know there is no god and then on
facebook later that day they're like
healthcare is a human
right
now what does this note rights are right
if you track the the notion of rights
and human rights
again it ties back in with christianity
with judaism with the idea of the
sacredness the dignity of the human
person you go back to like greek culture
roman culture there's no human rights
you what are you talking it's
but but what is it's a story
a story about
the sacredness the holiness of
people
even someone
who um maybe isn't the smartest
isn't the most gifted isn't at the top
of the power hierarchy
every person right has this certain
dignity what's where is that coming from
this is what nietzsche this was his
insight that he said those ideas are all
coming from christianity this is
basically his critique like you atheist
like you all think like i've left god
behind you're like but you're living
christianity like you're just you're
doing the christian thing it's so clear
from the way you're living you're like
yes i just um i don't know how do we put
it um
even you know the notion of like you
know we should all just be compassionate
people and love our neighbor as
ourselves you know like this is again
can you see how it's all like it's jesus
it's i think in other words i don't
think we've quite grasped just how deep
our christian roots go
like we don't even think of it as
christianity
it's just
what's true
right it's just because it goes so
deep for
us
um
so i could imagine you know again
someone kind of pushing back like well
here's the thing brad like i'll just i
don't know about all the god stuff and
all that but i just want to follow
christian ethics and i just want to you
know kind of do that aspect of it like
just love my neighbor as myself and you
know and i can say well
my only pushback would be okay
um i mean frankly i'm glad you want to
do that
um that's good you know but the thing is
it is a little bit strange
to um
to to kind of uh almost chop down
the tree
of
the the stories and the faith that is
feeding that way of life
and then kind of demanding that the tree
of that fruit
feed and nourish you
like it's kind of i imagine a little bit
like the analogy is like a you've seen a
cartoon character who's like sitting on
a branch and they're like
right and they're
and of course they're sawing the branch
that they're sitting on
right and then there's this moment where
they cut through but they don't fall yet
because there's like a cartoon character
they don't realize what they've done
right and i think that's the picture
like that's what nietzsche's saying is
happening we're there and we've kind of
sought to the branch but we don't
realize what we've done and so we're
just kind of
and we're like this could work this
could work right and it's like
[Music]
no
not long term which is kind of my my
second pushback would be um
of course it's true like i have many
people many friends who don't believe so
if you take this as like some sort of
rant against the horribleness of people
who don't believe it's it's not i'm not
saying they're horrible nothing like
that like they're some of my closest
friends um but i'm i'm just naming that
it's a little bit incoherent how they're
living because they've cut themselves
off from the story
that infused all of that with life
and and here's the thing we could do
that right like we've been many of you
have been so formed in christian faith
and such that even if you walked out the
doors and like never returned like that
that ethics those stories like that
stuff goes deep in you and you would
probably just continue to live it right
but here's the thing
your kids probably won't
your grandkids probably want
certainly your great grandkids right why
because we didn't realize it agreed to
which
um the whole tradition
like the immersion in that was holding
us up was sustaining that whole way of
life does this does this kind of make
sense um
so i want to the way i want to um
kind of close in and someone from the
band can come on up um maybe josh could
you
come up or someone whoever whoever can
play just need a little music
um
and um
what i want to kind of give us a little
space to do is kind of reflect on a
question
and uh the question is this um how kind
of essential has god and christian faith
um been to me
and kind of this past season and why
you know maybe it's become increasingly
important to you and you notice you have
a little like pen or pencil on your on
your seat and a piece of paper so that's
where you can do this exercise and maybe
it's become increasingly important to
you and you i want you to take a little
time to kind of reflect on why why is
that what is what is god doing in me
um
or perhaps you've been you know in that
season of being super casual you know
it's just kind of like oh i don't know
don't know if it really matters you know
um and if so i'd encourage you or just
invite you um to reflect
um on that
so um let me say a quick prayer and then
we'll give you some space for that lord
jesus i thank you
for tonight i thank you
um for this space to reflect
on hard questions
um
and and i ask that
that you would just speak
that you would speak
yeah we love you lord
it's in christ's name that i pray
amen
amen this will take just a few minutes
you can write and then the ban will
close us
[Music]
hope to feel your presence
i could just stay
i could just stay right where i am and
hope to feel you
hope to feel something again
i could hold on
i could hold on to who i am and never
let you
change me from the inside
i could be
[Music]
you have called me
you have called me higher
me
i could hold on
i could hold on to who i am and never
let you
change me from the inside
i could be safer
i could be safe here in your arms and
never leave home never let these walls
down but
[Music]
you have called me higher
and i will be yours
[Music]
so let your mercy
for me you have called me
[Music]
me higher
you have called me deeper and i'll go
where you will lead me lord
[Music]
okay so since i get the privilege of
holding a
microphone this wasn't planned i'm just
going to read to you
what i wrote
if that's okay
so god in my life it's very important
because without god
what's my purpose
a god in my life is my source of love
kindness and patience
he's the reason why i want the best for
my kids
he's the reason why i'm patient with
people that drive me crazy
especially bad drivers
uh i need not to just acknowledge god in
my life but i also need to draw from his
strength and power because without him
i'm nothing
um
i wasn't expecting this to hit me the
way that it did
and especially with the music the way
you guys are amazing with this music
but um
trying to close this
in a way that it hits where you guys are
as well is kind of a challenging thing
because i'm obviously a little bit more
emotional than i thought i was going to
be
um when i think about my relationship
with god and trying to deconstruct my
own process as well
i
always get back to the fact that i'm a
gay man standing in a church
which is a contradiction
if you know anything about my life
and if this is a privilege
a huge privilege
i can't even
words cannot express it
so with that being said
if any of this has resonated with you
guys
we really hope that this has brought you
back to and in touch with god
and if you are in need of prayer i would
love to be able to sit and pray with you
if you're a visitor
we love you we're glad that you're here
um we would love to keep in contact with
you we have this welcome cards if you
wouldn't mind i just found your name so
we just said that you're here and if any
of this ministry resonates where you are
and you feel the need to give we would
like to do that as well there's an
envelope in a box where you can do that
you can also do that online as well
so with that i'm going to close this
with a quick prayer
and have an amazing labor day weekend
[Music]
lord thank you so much for
this church
thank you for the people in this church
thank you for
just who you are and your son
and just giving us a sense of peace and
purpose
i pray that you help us to remember that
as we go on with our weak
and i pray that we draw into you in
christ i pray amen
[Music]
deeper and i'll go
me
[Music]